[Applause]
drew hello hello drew so great to be
here thank you so much for having me
first of all your book is amazing and
we're going to talk about that
throughout the segment
um but i started a beauty company
uh almost 10 years ago flower beauty
i know the beauty industry i love the
beauty industry
it cosmetics is like the biggest
juggernaut
i mean in the last decade it's really
been
the the company that we've all marveled
at
and please tell me how and why you
started it cosmetics because for us
in the beauty industry you're the one
yeah i mean it cosmetics you know it
started out of this like
season that i thought was a big season
of setback in my life i i thought i was
in my dream job working and
i always wanted to interview other
people uh and i thought i was you know
in my dream job and i started getting
rosacea
a hereditary rosacea for me it would pop
up in the form of these
big red bumps and it would break through
the makeup and
i'd be anchoring the news live and i
would hear in my ear piece and there's
something on your face or something on
your face wipe it off
and i went through this season of not
finding anything that could work um
for for my skin and i thought i was
gonna get fired and thought
it was a big season of setback and i
kind of learned this this big lesson in
life that sometimes our setbacks
are are really our setups um
for something we're supposed to do next
we just sometimes can't see it in that
in that season of self-doubt or hardship
and
anyways i got this strong gut feeling
like
what if you could create a product that
worked for you it's probably going to
help a whole lot of other people
um and drew it was kind of this moment
in my life where i was like oh my gosh
my gut's telling me to do this but
my head is saying oh you're not
qualified
you don't know anyone in beauty you
don't know what you're and in that
moment
i i made a decision to turn down all the
self-doubt in my head and
listen to my gut and launch it cosmetics
uh in my living room um but drew and
i know you know this from being a huge
boss
that you are launching a business is
so much harder than i could have ever
imagined and
i didn't know that it would be three
years before i could
afford to pay myself in three years of
every beauty expert telling me no
um that it that the the this company
would never make it and you know drew i
had this vision to put real women as
models and try to
shift culture and beauty um and all the
big
all the big department stores and beauty
retailers everyone everyone said no so
it was
three years of constant rejection
so it was a tough start and you yourself
had gone through a personal experience
of feeling
rejected yourself which is why you
wanted
the women in your campaign to look a
certain way can you tell me about that
um drew one time we were a couple years
into our business and
i didn't know how we were going to make
it we were down to under a thousand
dollars
and in my personal account and company
count combined
and i got a big call from a potential
investor um
and it's like a huge private equity
company and they loved our product and
they've made a lot of products we shot
that in the grocery store really
famous household names and i thought it
was gonna be my big break and we went
through all these meetings
and we got down to the final meeting and
i flew up for the meeting he was
standing about three feet from me
and he said it's a no we're gonna
pass on investing in it cosmetics i just
don't think women
will buy makeup from someone who looks
like you with your body
and your weight and i remember
i felt like this lifetime of bodied out
and self-doubt fled my body
i went into my car and cried my eyes out
and this feeling in the
pit of my gut said he's wrong and i just
felt it and i also never got mad because
i realized oh he's just like the rest of
us he's been impacted
by the beauty industry too but he thinks
you have to look a certain way
to be successful and six years later um
when l'oreal bought it cosmetics and it
made the press everywhere
for 1.2 billion go ahead
he i heard from him that day he said
congratulations i'm so happy for you
i was wrong and i learned it would have
been the most successful
investment in his company's history and
like drew
had he believed in me back then when i
was so desperate i probably would have
given him the majority of the company
for almost no money but by the time we
sold
the business i was still the largest
shareholder so i was like thank god he
didn't believe in me
and sometimes our hardships and our
setbacks and they
they are painful and they're unfair and
they don't make sense but
i just think that um when we keep
believing in the possibility of our own
dreams and hearing our gut and believing
our setbacks are our setups
and i think all things are possible so
well i um i'm glad you don't
approach that uh with an angry you know
reception i think your high road
you know approach to being able to hear
that and have the lesson learned that
you should stick with your gut instinct
is fantastic
i want to take out all my anger issues
on this man but you know i'm glad he
called and said congratulations it
took the sting out of it a little bit
for me but
yeah you know i have watched the
trajectory of it cosmetics
as someone who's living inside the
beauty business and
it's just incredible you started this to
help people
to solve a problem i i
love your products too i mean they're
just that they're they're successful for
a reason they're really
gold standard in the industry and
everybody's on the feeder of it
cosmetics as they should be
and jamie the fact that you're sharing
your story which is just
especially when you're in like a beauty
industry or like a hollywood game it's
got to be
about who we are inside and
what our journey is and the outside is
affected by that
it's not the other way in how we look
and then that's the journey
it's in here and believe it how to go
from being underestimated to unstoppable
is available now wherever books are sold
100
of the proceeds are going to feeding
america
my goodness what an amazing person you
are thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you so much
[Music]